[Aplausos]
[Música]
estoy seguro de que ahora tras el
desastre ruso que hemos presenciado
Pensarás que Moscú ha puesto todo su
músculo militar en Ucrania para que os
hagáis una idea han perdido ya más de
2.000 tanques en el campo de batalla lo
que representa más de la mitad de su
reservas vamos que Rusia no está para
otras campañas militares que no sean la
de Ucrania verdad pues nada más lejos de
la realidad atentos Estados Unidos culpa
al grupo Wagner de Rusia del
empeoramiento de la seguridad en Mali y
ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando
todos ahora pero qué interés tiene Rusia
en Mali quiero decir Rusia está aquí
inmalia está aquí que les importa a los
rusos lo que pasa en África si sois
veteranos seguidores de visualpolitik ya
sabéis que la madre Rusia tiene
tentáculos por todo el mundo Pero por
qué ahora Precisamente en África
pensando bien hasta 2022 Rusia tenía un
área de influencia muy clara en Asia
central y el cáucaso sin embargo un año
después todo ese poder se está
desvaneciendo kazajistán se está
alejando cada vez más de la Esfera rusa
y que me decís del conflicto ante
Armenia y azerbaiyán la disputa por
nagorno caravag durante décadas Rusia ha
jugado el papel de árbitro en esta
disputa Pero ahora ni está ni se la
espera es más muchos países que estaban
tradicionalmente en la órbita de
influencia de Moscú están mirando cada
vez más a Beijing sin embargo África
sigue en la agenda del kremlin y más
específicamente en la agenda del grupo
Wagner
ya sabéis que el grupo Wagner es una
empresa privada un ejército privado al
servicio de Vladimir Putin su dueño es
amigo íntimo del presidente Hablamos de
una empresa que no está teniendo ningún
problema en lanzar a sus hombres a
Ucrania Aunque ello haya supuesto
meterlos de lleno en un terrible
picadero de carne humana pero no sólo
están en Ucrania también tiene músculo
suficiente para África y la pregunta es
por qué Y hasta qué punto los países
africanos se oponen o no a esta
influencia rusa y la pregunta más
importante es Rusia la única potencia
con presencia en África evidentemente no
hay otro país europeo que nunca ha
abandonado sus sueños imperiales de
quién estamos hablando exacto de Francia
los que seáis veteranos seguidores de
visualpolitik ya sabréis que Francia
nunca abandonó del todo sus antiguas
colonias y también sabréis que el
colonialismo francés fue de todo menos
amable incluso ya os hemos hablado
varias veces de la competencia que
Francia y China mantienen por la
influencia en África sin embargo lo
cierto Es que la llegada de Rusia ha
puesto todo patas arriba y claro os
preguntaréis pero de verdad tanto
influencia puede tener un simple grupo
de mercenarios rusos como los Wagner
pues desde luego no es poca fijaos en
este mapa
Aunque la presencia rusa no es el único
motivo porque Francia todavía conserva
importantes tropas en África Lo cierto
es que últimamente esa razón ha cobrado
cada vez más peso para que os hagáis una
idea las tropas que Francia desplegó en
el sahel en el año 2013 hoy suman ya más
de 3000 efectivos y antes de La retirada
de Mali a finales del año pasado
llegaron a ser hasta 5.100 tropas Pues
bien a día de hoy Rusia contra ya con
3.000 mercenarios en África está claro
que son menos rusos que franceses pero
estaréis de acuerdo conmigo que son
cifras más o menos comparables por
supuesto También tenemos que contar con
las fuerzas internacionales como Los
cascos azules de la ONU pero seamos
claros la ONU no es precisamente la
panacea en lo que influencia se refiere
sea como sea Hay algo incontestable en
términos de influencia política Francia
sigue siendo la mayor potencia
extranjera en la región y desde luego su
peso es mucho mayor que el de Rusia
tienen más bases militares más contactos
en la zona y vínculos económicos más
fuertes ahora bien donde antes Francia
era prácticamente el único Sheriff en la
zona ahora está contestada por dos
grandes potencias China y Rusia sobre la
presencia de china en África hemos
hablado ya largo y tendido a quien
visualpolitik pero en el vídeo de hoy
vamos a centrarnos principalmente en
Rusia Así que la pregunta Entonces es
hasta qué puntos está desmoronando El
dominio francés en África Qué puedo
hacer Francia para mantenerse fuerte en
la región por qué puede ser tan
importante su presencia y lo que es más
importante qué intereses tiene Rusia y
Qué importancia tiene todo esto para la
Guerra de Ucrania hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
colonialismo a la francesa
en visualpolitik siempre hemos estado en
contra del colonialismo Y seguramente
hoy ya nadie va a empezar a decir venga
vamos a colonizar de nuevo América vivan
las colonias bueno alguno habrá pero
desde luego no seremos nosotros no
obstante tampoco podemos olvidar que no
todos los colonialismos han sido iguales
ha habido imperios coloniales que
dejaron algunas estructuras de gobierno
establecidas y que cuando se marcharon
bien voluntariamente o bien porque les
echaron lo hicieron por completo este
fue por ejemplo el caso del imperio
español con América sin embargo nuestro
protagonista de este vídeo Francia hizo
todo lo contrario
[Música]
Francia llegó tarde a la primera
colonización ya sabéis a la de América a
pesar de ello consiguió hacerse con
buena parte de Norteamérica y más tarde
con importantes territorios en el
sudeste asiático sin embargo no es esa
etapa del imperio francés la que solemos
recordar como la más próspera dominios
sino la del siglo XIX mientras España
atravesaba una profunda crisis perdiendo
sus últimas colonias americanas y
Filipinas en 1898 Francia estaba en
pleno auge después de la conferencia de
Berlín del 85 consiguió situarse junto a
Reino Unido como el mayor imperio
colonial de toda Francia Es cierto que
sus primeros asentamientos en el
continente se remontaban a mitad del
siglo XVII el senegal y que ya se habían
hecho con El dominio de territorios como
Costa de Marfil gabón y Argelia entre
1840 y 1850 pero no fue hasta 1885
cuando el Imperio francés alcanzó su
máximo esplendor de repente su dominio
en africa no tenía nada que envidiar al
británico y sabéis que Francia se volcó
en sacar el máximo provecho de estas
colonias ya fuera el Auro del alto
voltaje o el petróleo de Mali Francia se
dedicó a explotar la mayor cantidad de
recursos minerales posibles
desde luego crear instituciones
infraestructuras no era algo que entrara
para nada en sus planes seamos honestos
los franceses estaban allí para explotar
los recursos naturales punto no tenían
ningún interés en desarrollar sus
colonias más que lo justo e
imprescindible para que su maquinaria
extractiva funcionase a pleno
rendimiento de hecho El dominio colonial
francés Es especialmente conocido por
ser de los más crudos Como demostraron
por ejemplo las masacres de las ciudades
argerinas de setif Y gelma aunque Bueno
si queréis un imperio brutal esperad
escuchar las atrocidades de los belgas
en el Congo pero eso ya lo hemos
cubierto en otros vídeos sin embargo
todo empezó a cambiar después de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial Estados Unidos la
unión soviética podían tener muchísimas
diferencias ideológicas pero Tenían un
punto en común ambos creían que las
colonias tenían que desaparecer Así que
dicho y hecho la ONU creó el comité
especial de descolonización y los
imperios coloniales empezaron a
desmantelarse de esta forma Reino Unido
dejó atrás Nigeria y todas sus colonias
africanas España hizo lo propio con
Guinea ecuatorial y con sus posesiones
en Marruecos Pero qué pasó con Francia
pues amigos de visualpolitik la realidad
es que a Francia le costó mucho soltar
las riendas de estos territorios y de
hecho aún podemos ver grandes vestigios
de lo que fue su antiguo imperio veréis
antes de que las colonias francesas se
independizaran Charles de Gol el
mandatario francés logró que los nuevos
países aceptaran que Francia controlará
algo tan importante como sus Divisas y
así es como nació el llamado Franco cfa
[Música]
hablamos de la moneda de curso legal en
14 países africanos antes estaba ligada
al Franco francés y ahora lo está al
Euro y donde se guardan las mayores
reservas de divisa del franco cfa Exacto
en Francia en otras palabras que Francia
todavía mantiene un control enorme sobre
estas economías Y esto no es un vestigio
colonial que baje Dios y lo vea y ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando muchos hombre
Fonseca pues no está tan mal tener una
moneda una divisa ligada al Euro
significa que estos países han
conseguido evitar inestabilidad
macroeconómica al menos en lo que a la
política monetaria se refiere Y sí
tenéis razón pero el control de Francia
no sólo se limita a la economía
Francia también es bien conocida por
apoyar a gobiernos autoritarios Y diréis
por qué la respuesta está en una palabra
recursos naturales básicamente Francia
apoya gobiernos autoritarios a cambio de
que les den preferencia a la hora de
extraer recursos naturales y les
garantizan el control de dónde creéis
que sale todo el uranio para las famosas
centrales nucleares francesas pues
principalmente de níger antigua Colonia
del imperio francés donde la empresa
ahora no tiene casi todo el control de
las minas y Qué pasa cuando los
ciudadanos se levantan contra sus
dictadores Pues bien Francia no ha
dudado en enviar sus tropas para
controlar la situación y lo hicieron
desde el primer momento ahí está el
golpe de estado de 1964 en gabón y
tantos otros en el caso de gabón
hablamos de un golpe que tuvo lugar solo
cuatro años después de que el país
ganase su independencia de Francia en
otras palabras no te preocupes gabón
Ahora eres libre ahora bien siempre y
cuando hagas exactamente lo que yo
quiero que hagas dicho de otra forma
Normalmente se critican las grandes
potencias por ser paternalistas con sus
antiguas colonias el caso de Francia es
aún peor que el paternalismo no es que
Francia quiera exportar sus valores demo
en África o mejorar sus condiciones de
vida no su principal interés es mantener
el control sobre la riqueza natural de
sus antiguas colonias Y si para eso
tienen que mandar a tropas Para apoyar
al dictador sanguinario de turno no os
preocupéis porque no van a dudar ni un
minuto y como os podéis imaginar esto no
sienta bien en las sociedades de estos
países todo esto ha dejado un espacio
para que entre una nueva potencia que
seamos claros en este caso concreto es
bastante más amigable de quién estamos
hablando Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el nuevo amigo chino
para sorpresa de nadie china el gigante
asiático se ha convertido en un actor
fundamental en África y la verdad no
resulta extraño digamos que África tiene
los recursos que china necesita y China
tiene la capacidad económica para que
estos países africanos puedan llegar a
desarrollarse O al menos para que puedan
sacar adelante grandes proyectos de
infraestructuras además los mercados
africanos aún no han florecido del todo
así que China tiene la oportunidad de
estar ahí cuando eso ocurra para recibir
su parte del pastel y aprovecharse por
ejemplo de la mano de obra barata Así
que tanto empresas públicas como
privadas de China empezaron a
interesarse por invertir en países
africanos Aunque todo se ha dicho de
paso hay precedentes desde los años 60
con la primera línea de ferrocarril en
zambia pasando por la conexión
addisabeba yibutti terminado en 2016
china construido hasta el año 2022 más
de 6.000 kilómetros de vías férreas en
África y no sólo eso también invertido
en la construcción de parques
industriales como el de addis abeba
hospitales carreteras y muchísimo más
fijaos analistas china amplia su
influencia en África mediante acuerdos
de redes de telecomunicaciones os dais
cuenta de la diferencia china no se
limita a extraer recursos naturales
también está dando muchísimas cosas a
cambio
[Música]
china ha ayudado a los países de África
a estar conectados al mundo y a no
quedarse aislados para poder recibir
información en tiempo real no solo
estamos hablando de invertir en
infraestructura de telecomunicaciones
sino también de producir teléfonos
móviles a precios asequibles para sus
mercados por supuesto como os podéis
imaginar esto también se traduce en
influencia política han abierto decenas
de institutos confucio donde se enseña
al chino y además proveen la emisión
televisiva Lo que implica que millones
de africanos ven programas de televisión
favorables a silvin pero una cosa está
Clara china ha ofrecido a África lo que
Francia nunca hizo negociar como iguales
O al menos no tratarles como súbditos y
como os podéis imaginar Estos son muy
malas noticias para Francia Pero mis
queridos amigos de visualpolitik tampoco
nos engañemos la presencia china no hace
milagros África sigue teniendo muchos
problemas y uno de los más importantes
es el yihadismo A qué nos estamos
refiriendo pues atentos
Francia en caída libre
hasta ahora Francia ha mantenido su
influencia en África de manera más o
menos discreta vale Sí algún golpe de
estado por aquí participando en misiones
encubierta respaldando algún que otro
gobierno autoritario por allá lo normal
vaya pero en el año 2013 hubo un punto
de inflexión Francia volvió a entrar de
lleno al escenario político africano Y
diréis por qué Pues porque había
estallado la guerra en marzo
en 2012 maley tuvo que empezar a hacer
frente a la rebelión organizada en el
norte del país por el movimiento
Nacional para la liberación azahuatl
este movimiento que tiene vínculos tanto
con el yihadismo del grupo ansarding
como con al qaeda de magreb islámico
comenzó una durísima campaña de
insurgencia contra el gobierno central
de Mali cada vez conquistaban más
territorio y al final al gobierno no le
quedó más remedio que pedir ayuda a
Francia Así es como empezó la operación
serval a la que París destino unos 3.000
efectivos militares la intervención
resultó todo un éxito al principio se
acordó la paz con los Torres en junio
del 2013 y el entonces presidente oland
pudo pasear triunfal Por las calles de
bamaco la capital de Mali además la ONU
estableció una misión permanente de
mantenimiento de la Paz El minusma sin
embargo lo cierto Es que estaba duro
poco y ya en septiembre comenzaron de
nuevo las hostilidades en el país lo que
aceleró la expansión del terrorismo
yihadista en toda la región un
terrorismo que ha azotado especialmente
fuerte tanto a Mali como a Niger y
burkina faso
en resumen que la situación se volvió
descontrolar por completo y como
respondió Francia mandando más tropas la
operación serval dio paso a la operación
barcane que terminó en noviembre del año
pasado
Francia necesitaba proteger a sus
empresas extractoras de recursos como el
uranio del níger o el petróleo de Mali
lo que significa que los franceses se
centraron únicamente en luchar contra el
yihadismo en las zonas Donde había
recursos naturales conclusión los
problemas No tardaron en surgir el más
importante de ellos seguramente sea el
propio entrenamiento de los ejércitos
locales en principio pensaréis que no
hay nada malo en ello verdad de hecho es
lo que cabe esperar entrenar a los
ejércitos locales para que hagan su
trabajo pero sabéis que esto se ha
convertido en uno de los mayores
problemas fijaos en esta gráfica como
podéis ver en el año 2020 tanto en
burkina faso como en Mali hubo más
muertes de civiles a manos de las
fuerzas de seguridad nacionales que de
los propios yihadistas Y esto no resulta
extraño pensadlo bien los conflictos
étnicos son bastante comunes en esta
zona del mundo y normalmente los
ejércitos de cada uno de estos países
suelen estar dominados por una etnia
concreta de repente Francia se puso a
instruir y a cubrir de armas
occidentales a ejércitos que a su vez
estaban dominados por una etnia concreta
conclusión todas estas etnias usaban y
usan toda esa ayuda francesa para
masacrar a las otras etnias un ejemplo
burkina faso
el ejército está dominado por la etnia
Moshi que no dudó ni un segundo en matar
a gente de la etnia fulani y peul Y qué
pasa con todo esto sucede pues lo
previsible que los atacados buscan a
alguien que les proteja como quién como
los yihadistas y así es como entramos en
un círculo vicioso donde la ayuda
francesa se traduce en más violencia y
más yihadismo entendéis ahora porque
estos países no tienen muy buena imagen
de Francia eso explica que en agosto de
2022 mal y dijera Mira Francia que a ver
cómo te lo digo Muchas gracias por tu
ayuda vale pero ya si eso déjanos un
poquito en paz que nos apañamos nosotros
por nuestra cuenta eh venga eh Gracias y
hasta luego Y como os podéis imaginar el
resto de países vecinos van en la misma
dirección atentos
Francia acepta retirar sus tropas en un
momento en el que la imagen de Francia
parece estar por los suelos y la
confianza en este país está bajo mínimos
La pregunta es quién entrará a llenar
este vacío que deja Francia ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando todos en este momento
verdad china el amigo chino que trata a
los africanos como iguales les pone
infraestructuras telecomunicaciones y
hasta incluso les ha sabido
industrializarse pues no nada más lejos
de la realidad aquí es el momento en el
que llega
[Música]
el abrazo del oso ruso
no sé si alguna vez os ha dado por mirar
la bandera de mozambique pero vamos a
echarle un vistazo es esta no ves Nada
que os llame poderosamente la atención
Exacto lo que estáis viendo en el escudo
de armas Así cruzadito es un ak-47 el
fusil de asalto soviético más famoso de
toda la historia y en verdad aunque sea
algo fuera de lo normal tiene todo el
sentido del mundo al fin y al cabo esta
fue el arma más popular durante su
proceso de Independencia y en estos
procesos la unión soviética y sus
aliados hubo un papel importante en el
caso de muchos otros países africanos no
solamente con las presiones ante la ONU
sino también mandando armamento
instructores y tropic
de hecho como ya hemos adelantado al
principio del vídeo Rusia ya se ha
puesto manos a la obra a través del
grupo de mercenarios Wagner empezó en
Libia y en Sudán en 2017 y hoy ya se
encuentra también en mozambique Mali y
la República centroafricana y os
estaréis preguntando pero Qué
importancia tiene esto no es acaso otra
empresa privada más Pues sí es verdad es
una empresa más prestando un servicio de
seguridad pero hay algo más detrás de
esta empresa fijaos desde Rusia con amor
un Aliado de Putin extrae oro y juega
con favoritos en Sudán respaldada por el
kremlin la oscura red conocida como
grupo Wagner se enriquece en Sudán
mientras ayuda a los militares a
aplastar un movimiento democrático
Exacto mis queridos amigos de
visualpolitik el grupo Wagner está
ayudando a Putin a extraer oro y no solo
en Sudán en Mali También tienen derechos
de explotación sobre otras tres minas de
oro y otras tantas en la República
centroafricana sin embargo el principal
objetivo siempre ha sido burkina faso y
diréis Pero por qué
Pues porque en burkina fases extraen
anualmente 70 toneladas de oro lo que lo
convierte en uno de los mayores
productores del metal amarillo en toda
África En otras palabras que burkina
faso extrae todos los años la misma
cantidad que tiene Dinamarca en reservas
de oro y como os podéis imaginar putins
se frota las manos con noticias como
esta el grupo Wagner habría recibido una
mina burkina faso a cambio de ayuda a la
lucha contra los extremistas yihadistas
habéis oído bien a Vladimir Putin le
viene de perlas que el grupo Wagner esté
extrayendo el oro de África para lo
habéis adivinado financiar su guerra en
Ucrania Pero esto no habría sido posible
sin el fracaso de la lucha
antiterrorista de Francia en la región
ni el descontento generalizado que ha
creado París pero creéis que este
descontento si ha dado solo por esto no
habrá tenido algo que ver con Rusia pues
En parte sí porque Francia lo ha hecho
estrepitosamente mal Eso es cierto pero
Rusia también ha sabido jugar muy bien
sus cartas de Qué cartas hablamos de la
historia la propaganda del kremlin se
encargado de recordar a los africanos
quién estuvo de su lado cuando se
independizaron de sus potencias
coloniales y parte de que este mensaje
haya calado también se debe no a Rusia
today otras televisiones sino el grupo
Wagner que se ha encargado de hacer
campañas de marketing en favor de Rusia
en todos estos países de hecho desde
finales de 2019 Facebook ha tenido que
cerrar más de 300 cuantas asociadas a
priorin el jefe de Wagner que esparcía
propaganda rusa en más de 12 países
africanos así las cosas lo que está
claro es que mientras china le come el
terreno económico a Francia Rusia se
dedica a apartarle en materia de
seguridad Así que la pregunta es está
rindiendo Francia tan fácilmente Pues
bien veamos
[Música]
lo
un necesario cambio de rumbo
[Música]
a estas alturas está claro que la imagen
de Francia en buena parte de África es
desastrosa Es cierto que ha habido
varias veces en las que se les ha
criticado injustamente Como por ejemplo
cuando retiro sus tropas de mala y por
completo Entre múltiples acusaciones de
abandonar la lucha antiterrorista a
pesar de que había sido la propia Malik
quien les había echado pero la verdad se
ha dicho macron sabe que el papel que
Francia ha jugado en África durante las
últimas décadas ha sido muchas veces
reprobable precisamente por eso ahora
está redefiniendo su estrategia
el gobierno de macrón ya se ha puesto
manos a la obra en África y ha comenzado
a negociar nuevos acuerdos con los
países de la región de hecho ya se
comprometió a principios del año 2022 a
invertir en la construcción de
infraestructuras al igual que hace china
es decir Francia pretende hacer ahora lo
que otros países ya hicieron con sus
colonias en el pasado
Francia hace una china los proyectos de
infraestructura
además visto el fracaso de la operación
antiterrorista en el sahel Francia
quiere evitar una Estancia militar tan
prolongada en el futuro por lo que se ha
ofrecido impulsar la construcción de
academias militares en Costa de Marfil y
Booty entre otros países y no solo eso
Francia también ha ofrecido apoyo
logístico de inteligencia Y apoyo en
combate en situaciones puntuales
Emanuel macrón parece haber entendido
que la estrategia que estaba siguiendo
sus predecesores no estaba funcionando
la imagen de Francia se estaba manchando
más de lo necesario en el continente
[Música]
en cierta forma podríamos decir que
estas nuevas medidas se acercan mucho al
clásico poder blando del que ya hemos
hablado varias veces aquí en
visualpolitik dicho de otra forma menos
palo y más zanahoria sin embargo puede
que resulten insuficientes ante un socio
chino que les ha mostrado los países
africanos una vía mucho más ambiciosa y
una Rusia Aparentemente más capaz de
luchar efectivamente contra el
terrorismo por supuesto todos tienen un
interés claro recursos naturales Pero al
menos en principio parece que están
dispuestos a dar algo a cambio dicho de
otra manera Francia va a tener que
adaptarse a una África muy multipolar en
la que ya no será la potencia claramente
dominante pero ahora la pregunta es para
todos vosotros Hasta qué punto está
Francia dispuesta a cambiar el trato
hacia África después de 200 años de
colonialismo y poscolonialismo podrá
mantener su influencia y como Rusia
puede llenar los vacíos que vaya dejando
el ejército francés podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
como siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]